do you not think that there is a
fundamental part of us as human beings
that needs religion you could you could
say that there's a deep psychological
need for religion the comfort that you
get from believing a falsehood
um is like a drug and and it's a
perfectly
valid argument to say that there's
everything to be said for the drug
I just want to make a distinction
between what is true and what Humanity
needs and and it may very well be that
we do need false ideas in order to
flourish and prosper but I'm also
interested in what's true a lot of
people are zipping their mouths because
of
um a political pressure and if people
for political reasons are trying to deny
that there really are there really is a
binary separation between the two Sexes
then that is anti-scientific
anti-rational and is a subversion of
language actually
amazing
[Music]
hey Francis do you think Financial
platforms should be apolitical and not
cancel people just because they don't
agree with their politics I'll never
forgive what those absolute
that tied Bank did to us now Francis we
don't know if our bank account was
canceled because of our politics give me
five minutes in a room with them and
I'll find out what are you gonna do test
your new jokes on them yes and More
Celine Dion impersonation
don't want to see that
[Applause]
moving swiftly on if you're looking for
a crowdfunding platform then you have to
use give send go give send go is a
crowdfunding platform that is available
in over 80 countries and provides a
simple and easy ways to raise money
online they are politically neutral and
don't remove campaigns based on
political or ideological differences we
all know that a lot of crowdfunding
platforms cancel people if they don't
agree with their politics the more we
support companies providing alternative
models the more we weaken the power of
cancel culture what's more gifts and go
is a free platform powered by donations
which means that you get to keep more of
the money you raise other crowdfunding
sites charge between five and ten
percent ten percent of the total money
raised is a huge amount Gibson gold can
be used to raise funds for medical
expenses business ventures personal
needs churches non-profits funeral costs
and much more so let's take a stand
don't give your business to companies
that have made it clear they don't want
you choose hope choose Freedom choose
give send go go to
www.givesandgo.com and check out a
better alternative to crowdfunding
that's
www.givesandgo.com and support the
people who support freedom
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a terrific guest today is a world
famous evolutionary biologist prolific
author and one of the four horsemen of
the new atheist movement Richard Dawkins
Professor Richard Dawkins welcome to
chicken thank you very much oh it's such
a pleasure to have you on the show as I
said you're world famous but for our
audience you will already know some of
your story tell us a little bit about
the background who are you how what's
been your journey through life how do
you end up sitting here a set of huge
accomplishments throughout your life uh
talking to us how far do you want to go
um back to birth or or um as far back as
you want to go
I was born in British colonial Africa
and as my father was in the Colonial
service
and um they go our family came to
England when I was eight
and then I went to boarding school and
then Oxford
and at Oxford I uh was inspired by a
world famous biologist called Nico
tinbergen who later got a Nobel Prize
and I did my doctorate under him and
have done
um I've been an academic life ever since
first of all I went to University of
California for two years very Junior
assistant professor and then
uh I came back to Oxford where I've been
for all my life
um I was a tutor at Oxford doing the
rather unique Oxford tutorial system uh
and I started writing books and I wrote
a lot of books uh which for for a
general audience which many of them sold
very well and then I was given a
professorship with a public
understanding of science the Charles
simonia professorship of the public
understanding of Science and then I had
to that was my job then was to
communicate science
and pretty much that's what I've been
doing is communicating science I've
written about 16 or 17 books uh and um
retired oh about 10 years ago no longer
and carried out writing books and that's
where that's where it is indeed and uh
one of your first or was it the first
book The Selfish yes that's your very
first book that was a book that
revolutionized as a young student I
remember reading it and understanding
things that I never understood and some
of the challenges then to the idea to
The evolutionary theory for example
altruism were beautifully addressed in
that in a way that even someone who's
not an expert could understand
um that and you wrote that book almost
half a century ago now in 1970. I'm very
pleased to hear you say how much you've
had to influenced you because
um it's
it sums up my attitude to biology is
somewhat misunderstood mainly by people
who've read it my title only I think
it's a book about selfishness or even an
advocacy of selfishness which of course
it isn't
um quite the contrary
um and um yes it it it's colored my my
whole career really and one of the
things I wanted to ask you is as I say
that was 1976 and nearly half a century
ago
what things what uh discoveries have
been made what theories have been
posited that you think in your field and
also more broadly perhaps in science
have emerged in that half century or
nearly half century that you think are
some of the most crucial things for
human flourishing human development that
we've we've made in that period
I suppose the main thing is the the
flourishing of uh molecular biology
because I mean it was it was written
long after Watson and quick discovered
the the
um DNA double helix structure that led
to the to the unraveling of the genetic
code and they're realizing that biology
is fundamentally digital
and um that's what's really going now in
biology is dominated by this digital
view of genetics everything is digital
and um some people have asked me has
that changed the self-esteem would I
would I change it if I wrote it now
because of the revolution in genomics
and I think I wouldn't it's still
um
it's still valid as far as evolution is
concerned I mean evolution is the
differential survival of genes in gene
pools and that's
who could have been said in the 1930s
actually uh well it pretty much was
so Richard my question is how much does
biology dominate our lives as in our own
lives does it dominate everything do do
we have free will or is it are we just
purely a product of our genetics well
Free Will is a question that doesn't
necessarily need a biologist to answer
it
um it's a deep philosophical question
um and it's not a question that I think
you can answer by looking at genetics if
I mean if if we have
free will or we don't have free will
that won't be influenced by looking at
genes you can say
nothing that I do is anything other than
predetermined by by the things that
happen in in the world the molecules in
in my brain everything is is
predetermined
um and genetics will not just be a part
of that so there's not really a question
for a geneticist it's a question for a
philosopher I suppose
um
or any scientist and it's not a thing
that you'll that a geneticist has any
specific
um input on
and is it what
what Revolution that can you see coming
or is happening at the moment that you
actually get excited by because that's
the exciting thing about science the
changes The Innovation the discoveries
that we're seeing at the moment well I
mentioned molecular genetics and and
that's happening all the time it's not
it's not a single Revolution it's just
going on and on and on
um and so
um the fact that you can actually read
very swiftly nowadays you can actually
read the genetic code of any animal and
it's always the same genetic code and
what it says is in detail different and
so you can take any animals you like and
read the genetic code any people you
like and read the genetic code and
compare it letter by letter line by line
just as you might compare to manuscripts
and that's an astonishing thing I mean
that that would have amazed Darwin I
think and that means that you can
reconstruct the whole Tree of Life the
whole pedigree the whole family tree of
all living things
um in in my new detail you can say which
is the which pairs of animals and plants
are most of the closest Cousins you
couldn't estimate how far back they had
a shared ancestor that's that's only an
approximate estimate but but you can
roughly lay out the complete
history of
the branching tree of life by looking at
these molecular
genetic sentences
Richard and for someone like you who is
a scientist and who is uh I think
there's a sort of wondrous appreciation
of all these things and the beauty of
the natural world and so on uh what are
some for for our audience and and for us
actually what are some of the Practical
applications that come out of these
discoveries that we may not yet have
seen when we go to the doctor we may not
yet have experienced in our own lives as
a thing that's become part of it what is
coming as a product of this uh steady
slow but ongoing Revolution here's a two
doctors have treated us all as pretty
much the same I mean maybe a bit
different male and female and old and
young but apart from that if you've got
a certain disease you get a certain a
certain medicine a certain treatment
um
what will come is when doctors are able
to read the um if they can in principle
do it now but when it becomes cheap
enough that a doctor will know the
Genome of each patient then the
prescription that the doctor will give
or any particular disease will vary
depending upon the uh the genotype of
the individual patient
um in a very sort of crude way we
already have this when certain
particular diseases are known that bit
caused by certain particular genes
um but when everybody is patient when
everybody every patient's genome is on
file in the Doctor's computer say oh
okay well I look at me as I see your
genome so you better have this this drug
and the next patient you better have
this drug
um I think that that's the main thing I
can think of immediately off the top of
my head in answer to your question
Richard are you worried that no no for
from a medical point of view that sounds
incredible I'm like of course that is
wonderful that's what everybody should
have access to but you worry as well
that this type of information could be
used in a way to discriminate against
people for example to prevent people
getting health insurance because you
might have like the Baraka Gene and that
means that you have a 90 chance of
developing breast cancer that's a big
worry and uh it's one of the things that
needs to be looked at very carefully
because
um life insurance companies at present
have a very crude way of doing their
Actuarial calculations they look at your
age they look at whether you smoke
whether you drink to access that kind of
thing
um but um apart from that we're all
treated pretty much equally and that
means that
um that those of us who are um who are
healthier in a sense subsidizing those
of us who who get ill and that that's
the way Insurance works if if it came to
it that
um
genetic uh knowledge enabled
Actuarial calculators to say okay he's
got he's got another 25 years to live
he's got only 15 years to live
um then life insurance have become
impossible I don't think it'll come to
that because it's not that predictable
but nevertheless there would have to be
careful regulation I'm not sure how that
would work
I supposed to prevent insurance
companies getting access to
data which would have to be kept
confidential that would be one way to do
it another way I'm not quite sure what
how what the legality of it would be but
that is a big worry
and and also as well what it brings into
I mean the term designer babies is is
used I think it's more of a kind of
tabloid description but we know what we
mean where people where babies are then
having the screen for certain genetics
and certain genes are taking out are
taken out or eliminated or played with
do you think that scientist playing God
or do you think that's actually where we
need to get to as a species so thereby
eliminating certain illnesses diseases I
think it's hard to find an objection to
eliminating diseases so I think as long
as that's used not for making designer
babies but for
um
screening against hereditary diseases it
seems to me that that's really hard to
object to that
um do you not think there's a moral
conundrum there because it kind of
depends where you draw that line doesn't
it for example if you have a baby that's
I don't know has a higher risk of cancer
now I I have a a young son I wouldn't
want him to have a higher risk of cancer
but if I could then you know select them
from a number of fetuses and discard the
others wouldn't that be maybe perhaps
too far going in that direction well I
don't think necessarily so
um I suppose the way it might work this
would be something like this in IVF in
vitro fertilization
um the woman is given hormone treatment
to Super ovulate so she gets maybe a
dozen eggs and the dozen eggs are all in
in a petri dish
and what happens at present is that the
doctor picks out one of these eggs at
random they all get so fertilized as
they can picks out one of the zygotes at
random and re-implants it in the woman
well
um
if the instead of picking zygote at
random you you examine the genes and
this can be done when it reaches say the
eight cell stage so you let them develop
to the eight cell stage so they are
eight cell embryos and then you can take
out one cell of the of the aid
and look at the genes of that and it
doesn't damage it
and you say oh okay this one
has the gene for hemophilia this one
doesn't why on Earth would you choose a
random if you know
that some that half of them have have
the hemophilia and half of them don't
obviously it makes moral sense to pick
one of the half one of the 50 that do
not have the gene for hemophilia
whatever it might be I suppose the
question that it brings into and this is
part of the other conversation we want
to have with you
um in terms of atheism and religion it
brings into question uh life what is
life is a eight cells I got life can it
be discarded uh is that that that's
where the moral conundrum comes in I
have no time for those that kind of
argument about is this a human human
life you don't really no why not well
because
this eight cell zygote has no feeling it
has no nervous system it has no capacity
to suffer no capacity to feel pain
um so that there's the mean no no moral
difficulty at all in choosing you're
going to pick one of them anyway what a
dozen of them and the and the 11 that
you that you don't choose are going to
be flushed away anyway
so um you've already taken that moral
decision in a way it's a question of
whether you to choose one at random
whether you choose the one that does not
have the
but what I mean is once you've created
that selection process given that
parents would want their children to be
happy but also clever and now you've now
you've moved on to quite a bit different
topics yeah now you moved on to but
that's where I was going okay right so
and that's I think the core of France
yeah too is if we've got the opportunity
to select the optimum baby for us are we
not going to end up in a position where
parents are encouraged to go down that
path well yes incentivize them but
you've changed the subject to like I I
was talking about the removal yeah I'm
not trying to catch you out it's a very
interesting question and and then you
can say something like
um if it became possible to know that
all these of these dozen zygos that
we've got
um some of them have a gene for musical
genius and some of them don't
um we're nowhere near that at the moment
but but if if in the future that that
came about then would you worry about
parents who say I want my child to
to be a great musician or a great
composer a great mathematician
um and that's very interesting that's a
more difficult moral dilemma
um
if if you object to that then I might
say to you
why do you object to that when you don't
object to parents
even forcing their child to practice the
piano see you know you haven't done your
music factors today get all my videos
first practice because the only way you
will become a great pianist is by
practicing
six hours a day whatever it is
um why would you think that is
uh okay when you would not think it okay
to pick out a zygote from a petri dish
which contains a genetic predisposition
to be a great musician I'm not answering
the question but I'm saying that in a
way these sorts of moral questions can
best be answered by comparison with
other other things and I'm just
comparing this case asking sort of
question a moral philosopher might all
might ask
um what's the difference between
encouraging a child to practice the
piano is giving the child a head start
by giving it the
Gene of the of the ones that are
available in the petri dish in an IVF
situation
um to become a musician I suppose the
problem with with the answer to that is
we come back into the realm of religion
and morality because
I think the core of it is the idea that
the creation of life is some kind of
random Miracle it's supposed to be
sort of it's it's not supposed to be as
a word that I've introduced of course
but if we if we call it a miracle
um it's supposed to be random to some
extent it's supposed to be down to
chance when you when we start
interfering with that selection process
instinctively I I can't explain it
perhaps I feel a certain there's
something off about that
for me I know that's not a very rational
scientific argument but I do think
that's one a lot of people share
actually but it's not rational attitude
no I I acknowledge that it sounds as
though you're religious it does it does
which I'm not interestingly but I feel
that that is probably how a lot of
people do think about it
yes I suppose they do
um I think it more of a worry would be
if some mad dictator some kind of Hitler
started using these techniques and
mandating you know the selection of
blonde blue-eyed
Aryan
you know
um
the sort of thing Hitler might have
might have selected
um I was talking about more giving
parents the opportunity to have their
um to do the IVF in in a non-random way
um I I can sort of see that both ways I
don't I'm like but on the other hand if
you have a dictator who says we want to
breed in this country a race of people
who are who are of such and such a type
um that I think is deeply sinister
oh Richard because I heard this a lot so
when I was a teacher I taught for
instance uh children who were on the
autistic spectrum and they were quite
far on the autistic Spectrum so they
were non-verbal but I also saw children
who were autistic and as a result of
their autism some of them were highly
gifted in mathematics and would go on to
be scientists physicists etc etc you see
artists who have depression for example
very severe depression but that almost
gives them an insight into The Human
Condition and human suffering My worry
is with this we go okay we're going to
get rid of depression we're going to get
rid of autism and then you could argue
well look we're going to get rid of
we're going to lower suicide rates as a
result of that we're gonna
nonverbal autism will be eradicated
completely but also aren't we going to
get rid of the outliers the the the
great thinkers the people who look at
the world in a different way that move
our our species forward that's an
excellent point
um and and the one that I should have
come on to in anyway yeah
um when you do any kind of selection for
any one characteristic you're in danger
of having side effects but you know
which you never thought of so if you
select for
um
to to remove some kind of psychological
problem that it could well be that
you're then having a side effect of of
never getting any any genius
mathematicians of something of that sort
of thought you're saying I think that's
a very good point and um it's what it's
one of the problems with any kind of
eugenics election is that is that you
you don't know what the what the
byproducts are going to be of the
selection that you're that you're
engaged upon that's what I mean when you
have a dictator who says we're going to
breed for such and such you see this
with with reading animals you you read
for racehorses who have very can run
very fast and
and they break their legs I mean they've
become more vulnerable to
um leg breakages because you're reading
for one thing namely speed and in nature
that doesn't happen in in nature it's it
would be counterbalanced by selection
against breaking the legs well you're
only using a human example which is much
more serious
um where
um
Geniuses outliers as you rightly said
are
quite likely to be selected against if
you naively
um go for removing certain psychological
problems so there's this
there is something to be said for
letting nature take its course but I
think
I come back to the negative things of
these these sort of genetic diseases
which are which are I think anybody
would agree are undesirable like
hemophilia
um and and it seems it seems to me that
taking a moral letting that your moral
con concerns
over spill into forbidding the removal
of genetic diseases like hemophilia that
are obviously negative in all respects
um that that that's going too far and
Richard we have a lot of scientists
saying that they're worried about where
science is going the state of Science in
general free speech in University
scientists no longer being able to allow
to explore certain Avenues how do you
see the field of Sciences at the moment
are you optimistic or are you a little
bit more cautious um what examples are
you thinking of where scientists are not
allowed to well we see we for instance
when it comes to talking about the Sexes
yes and saying you know there's
differences between the Sexes yes
investigating the differences between
the Sexes yes certain scientists would
say look I I don't feel able to
investigate that anymore because people
will complain people will say certain
things about about me that you know that
I'm denying the existence of trans
people for example yes I think you're
right that um not just scientists but
but a lot of people are zipping their
mouths
um because of um a political pressure of
the thought that you're saying
um and it it is important I think for
scientists to to be honest and to uh use
language precisely and in a particular
case of sex that you mentioned it's one
of the few cases where there really is a
a bifurcation a binary bifurcation there
really are two Sexes and scientists have
to have to work on under that that fact
and if people for political reasons are
trying to deny that there really are
there really is a binary separation
between the between the two Sexes then
that is anti-scientific anti-rational
and is a subversion of language actually
Richard uh I I actually didn't want to
make this conversation in any way about
the cultural discussions around that
issue but since since we've come to it
do you sit there and sometimes have to
pinch yourself that you one of the most
eminent evolutionary biologists in our
society go on the on on the mainstream
media and you are asked to talk about
the fact that there's men and women do
you know yes do you not feel do you not
experience that as like a gigantic
progression I do I I do because
um I I've um one of the main points I I
like to make is that very often
um I call it the tyranny of the
discontinuous mind but to a far too fond
of making discriminations
um things like um well we're talking a
bit earlier about
um embryos when does when does an embryo
become human is there a particular
moment when an embryo becomes human no
there isn't it's a Continuum it's a
sliding scale there are sliding scales
everywhere we in universities when we
examine students we give them a degree
first second two one two two third and
we we insist upon making a divide
between one class and another when we
know perfectly well that the top of one
class is closer to the bottom of the one
above than it is to the bottom of his
own class and yet
the information about the sliding scale
is actually in bell-shaped distribution
in this case
um is thrown away when we divide we
insist upon making the Divide so
um the tyranny of the discontinuous mind
is one of my catchphrases
and if I look around and say is there
any case where there really is
a proper divide a real where there
really is no Spectrum
and sexism is the one thing I can think
of there really isn't a spectrum you
really are either male or female and so
um I do have to pinch myself when
um for once
uh
it goes the other way I mean there
really is no Spectrum there and um yes I
I do have to think and where do you
think this regression if you agree with
my use of it where does that come from
well in certain social sciences they've
been very influenced by what they call
post-modernism I never really understood
what post-modernism is in fact I think
so-called postmodernists don't know
either but I think it's something to do
with
um
the words meaning something that is
determined by politics
you don't you don't actually have a
fixed meaning of words like male and
female because there's an intellectual
movement in in the social sciences that
says that everything is a social
construct and male and feel it's a
social construct there's no real
validity to the con to difference in
male and female it's all a social
construct
um or cultural relativism the idea that
um different cultures have completely
different ways of classifying the world
and so and so it's just our white
Western way of looking at things that
um that says that there are there's a
divide between males and females or
something like like that and Richard
with this social uh constructivism thing
my sense is that is the erosion of the
concept of Truth itself
is is that too strongly I think it's
absolutely right to say that it is
erosion of the concept of truth I mean
it is valid to say that language evolves
and and what words mean today is not the
same as what they meant 200 years ago
necessarily a little thousand years ago
um and so we have to accept the fact
that words change them their meaning but
we also have to live in a world where
um we have to be able to communicate and
so we have to be able to say that there
are certain words that that at present
means mean such and such a present black
means black and white means white and
blue means blue and it and if if that
changes in 100 years that's okay but for
the moment we've got to use words that
everybody understands and words like
male and female
uh
pretty clear in everybody's mind what
that means and
um to come along and say oh that's not a
social construct
um is subversion of language subversion
of truth I think you're right do you
think that this is a religious belief
Richard I think it has a lot in common
with religion with religious belief
um it's different in that it doesn't
invoke anything Supernatural but it's
very similar in the ways that Heretics
are hunted down
we've seen this in Oxford recently where
Kathleen stock has been has been um
vigorously not almost violently
sometimes they are violently hunted down
then there's actually rather detailed
parallels with with religious
um Dogma
um the doctrine of um
Original Sin
um
Christian especially Catholics believe
that we're all born in sin we're all
we're all in we all inherit the sin of
Adam
they no longer think Adam ever existed
but somehow they've sort of then just
talking gone about talking about them
sin of Adam
um and so we all the moment we're born
we're born in sin we have to be baptized
to be cleansed of sin that kind of thing
but I think we see that in the
Collective guilt that all white people
are supposed to inherit because of
slavery and even if they obviously they
have no direct connection with slavery
who maybe even need to never had an
ancestor but Mr probably did but
um and
we're all
collectively guilty for what people of
of our type did in some past
age and that is original sin I mean it's
exactly like original sin Francis Mayo
jump in just very quickly Richard you
said there's nothing Supernatural do you
not think that the claim that you can
change your sex by means of incantation
is a claim I mean yes I mean you could
you can make that case
um it's not quite Supernatural in the
same sense as as believing in gods or
believing in in fairies
um but yes it's sort of like that
um let's take in another religious
example the Catholic belief in
transubstantiation where the consecrated
wine and bread
becomes the blood and Body of Christ
and the
the way they put this is is to use the
Aristotelian idea of substance
Essence something an accidental so so um
um the Aristotle made the distinction
between the the the real substance
and and the and the accidentals and so
they they said well the accidentals of
wine is still wine in this sort of
accidental sense but in real substance
it becomes the blood of Christ and
that's the verbal trick that they use to
to justify this ridiculous idea that the
blood becomes that's why the wine
becomes the blood of Christ
um so yes that's very very similar to
you're quite right that's very very
similar to say that it's an incantation
that you say I stand up and say I am a
woman therefore I am a woman therefore
everything about me is there's a woman
you're not allowed to misgender me I'm
not allowed to say anything against the
idea that I'm a woman that's very very
similar to to the
accidental and real substance argument
of Catholics in the accidentals may may
say I'm a man I still have a penis but
in my real substance I'm a woman and
that's very very similar yes
Richard no you you're obviously a very
famous atheist and you've written
fantastic Works talking about your
atheism
do you not think that there is a
fundamental part of us as human beings
that needs religion
yes very possibly there is
um it doesn't mean it applies to
everybody it may mean that there's just
a
um it is quite difficult to eradicate
when you have something as fundamental
as that and and yes
um and I suppose a psychologist could
delve into that and and say something
like you we all need
um to believe in something higher than
ourselves we have a desperate need to
believe that we're not going to
disfizzle out when we die
um so yes uh you could you could say
that there's a deep psychological
need for religion it doesn't mean
everybody has it it doesn't mean that
that you can't get out of it but but
there's probably something like that to
explain it and because being critical of
organized religion as you were was there
did you ever think that you might that
you went too far with your criticisms of
God in particular or would you look back
on and go no I was absolutely justified
in what I said at that particular time
um
I I've always
tried to seek the truth and uh I've I've
never wanted to be um I never wanted to
upset people
um but I just think that we should be
free to argue points
and um
so uh I don't think I've gone
too far you could possibly dig out cases
where where you you might challenge me
and I might say yes perhaps I did go too
far there
um
but um
I think in general I've always just
tried to be loyal to the truth
I think that
religious claims are not trivial and I
think that they're very interesting
um it it's in a way is one of the
biggest questions that perhaps the
biggest question there is in science is
is
does some kind of
Supernatural intelligence look
behind the universe is the universe a
planned
um
entity that there's a super
supernatural being conceived I mean
that's a profound scientific question if
it's true then we're then the entire
universe we're looking at is a very
different kind of Universe from one
where there's nothing behind it
um and so it's a very very deep
scientific question
um and I think the the answer is clear
there is none
but I I don't write it off as something
trivial because I don't write it off as
a case where you can just say
um
it's not interesting course is
interesting
um it's interesting scientist has got to
be interested in this suggestion that
the sort of universe we're studying is a
planned designed universe that's a very
very different kind of universe so it's
a very it's a very deep question it is a
very deep question because
I I sense and I'm not a scientist that
the more you discover about the world
the more you learn about the Beauties
the details the intricacies the way
things are interlocked together isn't
maybe a part of you that thinks
this can't have been an accident there
must be something else here
it's very very tempting to say yes
everything works so perfectly together
and the the for me as a biologist the
complexity of Life the the enormous
panoply of plants and animals and
forests and birds and insects everything
working together now it's it's a huge
beautiful construction and
what for me what is absolutely marvelous
is that nevertheless there is a
perfectly decent explanation that it did
all come about without without planning
so one of the beauties of it is
precisely that we now can explain it
well well on our way to explaining it
without invoking any kind of
Supernatural intelligence and it is a
great Temptation because
um we are so used to the idea looking at
our own machines looking at things that
we've made like computers and cars and
planes and these are
clearly
the result of design deliberate design
deliberate construction and when you
look at something like a bird's Wing
compared with an airplane's Wing the
Temptation is huge to say they must both
be designed and it was the genius of
Darwin to break away from that and so
you actually know there is a proper
explanation there is a
materialistic explanation for that
um and so so the flip side of of the of
the Temptation is that when you've
overcome the Temptation and worked out
that it is possible to explain it in
simple scientific I really mean simple
because the idea yeah I don't say
there's a deeply simple idea and yet
given enough time
the darwinian idea of natural selection
given enough time can build up to
prodigies of complexity and beauty
and the illusion of design and that's a
that's a measure of the genius of Darwin
to see that and Richard in your book The
Blind watchmaker you make that point I
think beautifully and I do actually
think that just slightly no disrespect
to France it's probably one of the
weaker arguments against your position
what I think is a strong strong argument
is the one he made earlier and this is
about the psychological need people have
for religion but also at the level of
society and this is really something I
want to get into with you uh no your
Harare for example in his book sapiens
his Central argument is that the reason
Homo sapiens were able to out-compete
other species of human human or
humanoids humanits
was that
um they were able to build shared myths
that allowed them to create tribes that
went beyond the 150 limit of sort of
being able to know everybody and
when we look at the world today our
generation I when you're not in the room
I sometimes refer to us as you know the
children of Dawkins and the children of
Hitchens in the sense that you took away
with your beautiful books our ability to
have that illusion that the world around
us is you know this god-created
mysterious place for which there's no
other explanation
but as I look around at the world with
its inability to agree on what words
mean uh that what people call now the
crisis of meaning where a lot of people
are kind of lost they don't know what
the purpose and meaning of their life is
do you worry that maybe the truth is
that for Richard Dawkins your world view
is perfect because you are Richard
Dawkins you're able to be inspired by
science by the beauty of the natural
world by the beauty of the universe but
for a lot of other people what they
actually need is not necessarily the
belief in God so much as the social
function that religion used to fulfill
which is to bind us together with a set
of shared values and a set of shared
morals and a set of shared ideas about
what it means to be human what it means
to relate to other people and without
that we are lost and therefore we create
these new religions that sort of tear
our society apart I think it's very
interesting and I I'm
um rather persuaded by harare's argument
um and but but notice what you've just
done I mean you you've said
um maybe humans need religion maybe they
need something to bind Society together
and function of the yield and so on and
maybe they do that doesn't make it true
oh I agree with you and of course you do
um and um
some other stuff yeah no I mean it's
just that you can make a an utterly
watertight argument with Humanity needs
something which is false yeah all right
fine and and
um
I just want to make a distinction
between what is true and what Humanity
needs and and it may very well be that
um that that we do need false ideas in
order to flourish and prosper but I'm
also interested in what's true and um so
I mean I don't want to get involved in
that sort of starfish idea that that so
it's okay for for us intellectuals
Pursuit but but Hoy polloi
um need religion
um but I wouldn't consider myself an
intellectual so I'm I am the hoi Paula
in this in this context but I'm just
saying to you I I to me truth is a
supreme value and I agree with you but
at the same time to me the cohesion of
our society the fact that people are
able to live a life of meaning and
purpose uh they're able to connect to
other human beings and be fulfilled in
their lives and know what to do and you
know you don't have people who are
disappointed with the way that their
life has gone because of the choices
that they made because they didn't have
someone encouraging them down a
particular path that to me is also very
tragic as as tragic as the erosion of
the concept of Truth and I feel there's
a balance to be struck that that's what
I'm saying yes I think that's that's a
very good point and and um
I perhaps I should say accepting the
possibility of that I might also say
that actually there's something
wonderful about truth itself of course
and um so you can you can lead a very
very fulfilled life in the search for
Truth uh and um so that's my argument
you can yeah you can you are a scientist
you spend his whole life pursuing the
truth with a microscope and whatever
other tools you use right I haven't I
can't that's not what I can do and
that's not what a lot of people can't do
it's not because they're Stu more stupid
than you it's just because they're not
scientifically minded maybe they they're
musicians or whatever and and they don't
have that same mindset as you do they
don't have the same brain as you do
that's the argument I can't get involved
in using myself
um but but um I I just want to repeat
that that that you don't act well okay
you don't actually have to be a working
scientist you can you can you can Revel
in the beauty of a scientific
understanding just as you can Revel in
music without actually be able to play
an instrument
um and um
there is there is immense fulfillment to
be had in appreciation of understanding
of the universe in which you live and
why you live here and why you exist that
that's a wonderful thing and I I don't
want to accept the idea that only
certain people capable of doing that you
won't actually have a microscope in
order to do that you don't you can read
books you can see
the Cosmos television series you can see
David attenborough's films
um and there's huge satisfaction of the
kind of thing that has those religion
aspired to do in past centuries
um and you can you can get it by
almost worshiping not worshiping in the
sense of worship anything Supernatural
but the the the the the the the Wonder
of their own existence and the process
it has given rise to you to you that is
led to your existence which
Wonder of Wonders we knew we know pretty
much understand I mean it's a privilege
to be alive
in the 21st century and to be in a
position to just read a few books and
see a few television documentaries and
understand why you exist that's never
happened before
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
I I think the thing that
the thing that religion gives people is
a sense of safety almost so for instance
if when somebody is very ill and maybe
they have cancer and they don't know if
they're going to live or not
this knowledge that there is a Supreme
Being looking after them or there's
somewhere that they're going to go
afterwards provide someone with a deep
sense of comfort in the darkest moments
of their life and whilst I agree with
everything that you said about science
and Discovery and The Wonder of looking
at the Universe I don't think that
provides that particular emotion do you
see no it's probably true and um again
you can say
um that the the Solace that you get the
comfort you that you get from a belief
even if it's false it nevertheless is
comforting
um uh you've probably read Aldous
huxley's Brave New World where
um
um the uh towards the end the Mr Savage
the word of the person has brought from
the reservation and who is who has
actually got access to reading
Shakespeare and things he has an
argument with the world controller about
whether
dulling people's senses with Soma with
the drug that they that they all have to
make them feel good
um comparing that with
um the the
um depth of emotion that you can get by
reading Romeo and Juliet or or fellow
um and the Savage is advocating
Shakespeare
and the world controller is advocating
the
pacification of people with with it with
this drug that makes them all feel good
in a way the
the comfort that you get from believing
a falsehood
um is like a drug and and it's a
perfectly valid argument to say that
there's everything to be said for the
drug
there are of course real drugs you can
take it doesn't have to be a full speed
disability
so more equivalent well well that I mean
that is absolutely true it's you know
it's that drug is is such a powerful
thing you you see I can I've got to the
stage in my life Richard where I can
tell a lot of the time if someone is
religious because there's a lightness
about them there's almost that that kind
of existential dread which hangs off
atheists and maybe I'm projecting
somewhat they don't seem to have
not my experience
um uh I would say you have the same
lightness by the way absolutely yes okay
I I I'm not sure that that would stand
up to a serious investigation
a controlled experiment may not well
okay I mean we've got nothing but
anecdotes um yeah anecdotes I've heard I
I was close to somebody who
um was in was look looked after an old
people's home and she said that
um people who are really afraid of death
are the Catholics
um and that seems surprising in a way
but remember there's hell as well as
heaven and
um there's Purgatory before you get to
to either
um and so
um I think we need a bit more
investigation before before
you get from from um Richard and what
about you because uh you're in your 80s
now you're in extremely great shape both
physically and mentally but you are in
you know you are in your 80s and so the
moment is coming uh for you at some
point I hope very very far away uh an
atheist uh deathbed conversion is not a
thing that's unheard of uh how do you
have that lightness it's a often it's a
myth I mean there's a there's there's a
myth that Darwin hadn't had a deathbed
conversion which is utterly false
um I guess what I'm asking is how do you
have the lightness that you have how do
you face death I think that
um well uh
I think it was Mark Twain said
um I was dead for billions of years
before I was born
I never suffered the smallest
inconvenience
um it's going to be just the same as
before we were born we were we were we
were not there during the whole of the
Cambrian and the ordovician and the age
of the dinosaurs and everything am I
going to be not there after we're dead
so we have this brief time in the sun to
have a full and fulfilled life which is
what I am doing and intend to go on
doing until I can't anymore
um the the process of dying
as opposed to being dead the process of
dying is often very disagreeable
well that is the most British
understatement we're not allowed to
we're not allowed the privilege that a
dog has of being taken to the vet and
put painlessly to sleep maybe I should
identify as a dog
if I'm not allowed to go to the vet and
ask to be put down or or if the vet
refuses to put me down I could sue him
for Miss species
um so um okay I mean if there is
something frightening about being dead
it's the idea of Eternity yes and
Eternity is a sort of frightening idea
whether it's before you're born or after
you're born it's a kind of frightening
idea
um and so the best way to spend eternity
therefore is under a general anesthetic
which is exactly what's going to happen
Richard I was going
under a general anesthetic
do you was it part of you when you were
at the Forefront of the new atheist
movement that thought you were going to
defeat religion that you were using
facts and scientific reason and logic
you were going to
defeat all of these different religions
I was never that optimistic
um no I don't I don't I don't think I
ever thought that and and there was no
no movement I mean would you know would
four or five books came out of Russia at
the same time that by coincidence that
there was never an actual movement I
think it's a journalistic invention were
you uh close with Christopher Hitchens
well I I didn't know him that well I I
met him from time to time
um I I had a long interview with him for
new Statesman I think it was the last
interview he ever had before he died in
in a
in Texas where he was um being treated
and um
so yes but I I wasn't one of his close
circle of friends like Martin Amos and
salmon rushed you and what were your
thoughts or impressions of him what kind
of person was he oh
um immensely eloquent immensely erudite
um the most eloquent speaker I ever
heard I think
uh and um
and a huge loss I mean wonderful
intellect wonderful
amount of English language a command of
facts
um command of historic and literary
reference
Richard we would talk we were before I
asked you about the atheism question you
sounded as if you were pro-euthanasia
are you in order to alleviate suffering
at the end of someone's life
with this with safeguards
I think you do need safeguards against
um
you know
let's get rid of Granny sort of thing
um you've got to get on the housing
ladder somehow Richard yeah
um I think that there have to be
safeguards and and there can be and and
[Music]
um legal Scholars look into the
possibility but but given given that uh
yes I am I think that um
um we we should have the right to
um end our lives when we want to
um
I know of of cases I've personally come
across cases where somebody has
committed suicide in a not very pleasant
way
um because
they still had the power to do so
and if they had waited any longer
then they would have been incapable of
doing the act themselves
and therefore their lives were actually
made shorter
by Suicide
because they didn't have the comfort of
knowing
that if at any time later on when they
would no longer physically capable of
killing themselves they could ask a
doctor to do it for them you understand
what I'm saying yes absolutely
absolutely uh Richard I want to before
we wrap up and ask you our final
question and go to locals where our
audience get to ask you questions I want
to ask you a couple of uh just like uh
one-off questions which is one of the
things that a lot of people are talking
about now is the emergence of AI
uh it's not your field of expertise do
you have any thoughts on the development
of AI as we currently have it I um
had a go with
chapter
yeah yeah
um and I was quite interested in that um
it's factual knowledge is lamentable yes
yeah um I mean it's actually quite comic
uh um I happen to be interested in
JBS holding
um who was a great great biologist I
can't remember why that subject came up
and um his wife his third wife I think
was a woman called Helen spurway
who was a geneticist
um and I can't remember why I asked a
question about Helen spurway but I did
and it said
Helen spurway was married to Richard
Dawkins
and um
regarded by this and
um later on about three weeks later I
thought well I'd check up again so I
said
um
who was Helen spurway married who was
Helen spurway married to and he said
Aldous Huxley which again was false
um
so
I don't understand quite why it's
factual knowledge of silly details like
that is so poor because
anybody can Google something now I mean
why didn't they just Google Helen
spurway and come up with the correct
answer which is that she's married to
she was married to JBS Holden I mean it
would take about two seconds for a human
to do it alone for aai to do it so
um that's just a I suppose of Legally
amusing anecdote about factual knowledge
um
which is said that the the people are
using it to write essays and things like
that it is pretty impressive um
if you if you ask it to
um
give up to to write an essay
about something in the style of somebody
or other
it produces something pretty impressive
or you I we could probably ask it to
write an essay on
um Evolution with the style of William
Shakespeare and and it would produce a
pretty good Pastiche of Shakespeare's
Style
um
well I'm not quite sure I haven't really
been into as you write the said I
haven't really been into the things that
worry people about it but but I I'm
I'm alive to the possibility that there
are grave dangers in
something getting out of hand getting
out of control and and do you have some
sense of how that might play out
not really I need to do more reading on
the subject I think I mean I need to
read some of the people who aren't
seriously worried about it or who I
respect well one of the concerns there
was an article now I don't know how
accurate it was but it is an example
whereby they were training some kind of
military system of AI to choose targets
and then a human operator had the final
decision over whether that Target should
be struck or not with a missile uh and
allegedly according to this article the
because the human operators sometimes
denied
a strike on valid targets for other
reasons the AI decided that the human
operator was the obstacle in the way of
destroying the targets that needed
destroying and in the simulation
attacked the human operator right that
is a sort of so the argument about AI at
least seems to be that it's a baby now
and it's getting the wives of the people
wrong because it's still learning how to
walk and talk but eventually it could
grow up to be like a Hitler or whatever
you know what I mean yes I think I think
that's a very valid point and I could
imagine
um
some kind of AI
us to determine what would be the best
thing for the sum of Happiness would be
to exterminate everybody because because
we're all miserable yeah yeah
um
yes I as I said I need to read more
about it I think it's it's interesting
and
um
I'm in favor of
uh looking cautiously into the future
and saying about all sorts of things
what what kind of dilemmas are likely to
arise in the future what kind of
problems is scientific progress and this
is one ai's as one example scientific
progress likely to to raise in future we
need to be prepared in advance
for what's going to happen and I I
certainly have read enough to know that
um
AI is capable of doing things which are
really beyond our dreams at the moment
and who knows where that will lead and
now other question I wanted to ask you
in this part of the interview is this on
the balance of probability are we alone
in the universe and second part to that
question if we're not Is it wise to seek
contact with those other sentient life
forms I think the balance of probability
is that we are not alone if we are alone
in the universe then that has
interesting implications it means that
the origin of Life on our planet was a
supremely improbable event so improbable
that we're probably wasting our time
trying to work out how it happened
um but I don't believe that and I I do
actually believe that we are one of many
um
uh life forms in the universe and I
would love to know what what the others
are like I mean I'd love to know how
unique we are I'd love to know why I
could make a few predictions I mean I
think I could predict that
um there's gonna it's gonna be darwinian
um it's going to be um it's going to
have some kind of digital genetics
um there's not to be there's got to be a
very accurate genetic system where you
could make predictions of that of that
sort
um
Is it wise to uh well first of all
there's a very there's a big distinction
between life and sentient life
um uh intelligent life uh the um
intelligent life is a big step further
and so it says there's probably a lot
more life around than there is
intelligent life around it's a big
barrier to get through there
um and intelligent life if we ever
encounter it we're almost certainly
encounter it not physically we would
actually meet them
because the distances will be too great
um but
um we will most likely to meet them
through radio waves
um seti is such an extra restaurant
intelligence where they have actual
dishes pointing out looking for signs of
intelligent life
um
I don't think it's likely to be unwise
to respond to any such messages that we
find that we hear because
the distance is again are so great and
um you won't be able to have a
conversation even even that
nearest Style
um is is is
so far away that you could you could
only send a message and then you'd all
be dead before before you get with
current technological levels of
development wouldn't we be a little bit
like the Navajo sending a message and a
bottle to the two well it's been yeah
but but if you believe Einstein um then
then there is a limit to to
how fast information can can travel is
it limited to the speed of light yes
um and so
um the the I mean the two science
fiction books that I've read which
um come to grips with that that problem
is you you
um Fred Hiles
um
Ava Andromeda and uh Carl Sagan's
contact well
um both authors face up to the fact that
um resistances are too great for Direct
control of humans for different direct
manipulation of humans we don't have to
fear that they actually come in flying
sources and and run our lives how and
you can't run people's lives by radio
unless
both books face this come to the same
conclusion
the the instructions are build a
computer
which will then
control Humanity both authors I don't
know what the independently thought of
it or whether one of them I forget which
of those books came first
um so the the Extraterrestrial
intelligence sends information
telling people to build a computer which
will do certain things
and the the original senders of the
information may be long dead
because it takes so long for the
information to get here
but once the information is here then
the computer
can work in short-term time and come
um manipulate us and and in both cases
um that that's what very interesting
science fiction idea
and that's I think the only way we need
to be afraid we're not going to be
visited by people in flying sources that
I think is too improbable
Richard what an absolute pleasure thank
you so much for coming on the show the
final question we always ask is what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that we really should be
well I suppose they've sort of touched
on with really the looking into the
future we don't know what's going to
happen and we know looking into the past
um that we are horrified by certain
things that we did in the past like
slavery
and and maybe what we should be doing is
looking into the future and imagining
what will our descendants look back at
our time
and shudder with horror at what we did
um in the same way as we look back
two or three centuries and Shadow with
horror
Richard thank you so much for coming on
the show it's been an absolute pleasure
and please make sure to join us on our
locals where we'll be carrying on with
this conversation
Elon Musk is
us as an evolution
successful second planet means the human
race in our evolution
foreign
[Music]